good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday we are
so glad to be back in studio with
jacqueline hello because i literally
almost fainted after yesterday's show
like the work between
reading the dear toasters getting all
the stories and i didn't have an ipad i
brought my ipad it was obviously dead
i just i have a newfound appreciation
for your contribute contributions
wow thank you so much i couldn't believe
how hard it was like not only choosing
the stories which is a lot of pressure
but staying on top of the story is
because sometimes as we're sitting here
recording things break like kim's
statement did yesterday
right very crazy i watched um the first
half of yesterday's episode i'm so
excited to treat myself later and watch
the second half
i actually i never watch our episode but
i did watch it because it was funny i
really love a snitch on the toe
situation
it seemed as though she was so snitchy
of course snatchler did not learn her
lesson
that much is clear but just to have her
back on this show
it's just it's so it's such a treat and
you know what i have a newfound
appreciation for this show for a few
reasons one
i was watching you in the snatcher and
it was just so fabulous like
i felt truly like a toaster i had the
experience
of you know looking at the set and the
girls and the vibes they were
completely steamy yes and two not being
here yesterday i really had fomo
of missing the show i just love this
show i love participating in it i love
watching it and i just have appreciation
for the show no sometimes you need to
take a step back in order to see the big
picture
yeah and that's what you did yesterday
and i'm so glad that you were able to
have that moment you know at that moment
i had that perspective i was upstate in
the hudson valley just this state when
you get outside the [ __ ] that is new
york city
is fabulous bucolic some would say it
was so bucolic we had a nice day trip i
got back this morning i listened to
like we drove back this morning so i was
able to listen to the radio um the radio
host call thursday friday eve
and what hosts i just thought i don't
know whatever i was listening to in the
interesting thing
so i just have like radio host energy
well that's great i have taylor swift
energy so i came to the show like
i literally walked in and the room was
just a little bit brighter like i have
an extra pep in my step today because
i was delivered this morning just the
most wonderful fabulous exciting and
unexpected piece of news
and we are obviously going to talk all
about folklore
but um it just it gave me like a little
extra pizzazz
you have some i have for sure yeah
super oofy i can't wait to get into
vibes only
oofy vibes only yeah i mean it's weird
to talk about anything other than that
right now considering that's like you
know
the thing of the day and demi lovato
like props to her as well
there is one flaw in this show it's like
the way that we format it sometimes
there's like such breaking news that
of people literally only tune into the
show to like hear about it and we have
to like daily daily for 10 minutes
before we can get into the past five no
we don't have to dilly dally and i feel
as though if i
wasn't off yesterday like we now have so
much catching up to do like it's a whole
24 hours where we didn't really chat so
much now i know
so i feel like we could talk forever but
i guess we could get right into it and
just
but if we don't dilly dally then we have
a tdap 24-minute show
that's very true so let's dally claudia
that's true speaking of has everyone
watched my comedy special yet i'm sure
i saw a lot of people watching it last
night oh theo just propped up he wanted
to let you know he saw it
he thought it was beautiful and he wants
everyone to go and stream it hi
beautiful boy
hi hi beautiful boy hi angel
he's looking super angelic today i don't
know why you fed him well it's really
not hard to look angelic when you are an
angel
it's true but i feel like even angels
have bad days no even angels have flaws
yeah it's a real it's a real message to
everyone it's nobody's perfect nobody's
perfect you've got to work it
um so i think it's okay do you want to
tell us um anything about your day like
did you see a moose
um i did not see a moose but i brought
some farm fresh eggs
uh here's the show straight from the
coop i'm so excited i'm going to go home
um so hannah montana moves me so hannah
montana movie
like i'm literally gonna make farm fresh
eggs right after this they're one day
i'm getting farm fresh eggs for
breakfast
that's such an iconic scene in the movie
when she's like trying to catch the
eggs from the coop yeah and i think that
these eggs were made by you know happy
loved chickens right and i think i'm
gonna taste that
in my scrambled eggs later today are you
um
did you actually go into the coop and
gather no i did not so the crate was
made for you
the crate yeah it was a pre-made crate
but like
10 minute old egg much like the much
like the crates you get in the grocery
store no no but i stopped the chickens
yeah um you know that's exciting like
isn't that exciting
honestly now that i'm gotten into
cooking a little bit in quarantine
you really have a new appreciation for
the ingredients that go into your food
yeah i mean now that i've started
cooking and like putting my hands on
rummy like i totally understand
vegetarianism it's so sad and disgusting
yeah but i just love like pasta
bolognese too much
i know but you can use beyond brownie
you liked what i made i mean like i
could i could i'm not gonna lie when i
did eat your bolognese
like i just ate the pasta not like the
fake meat well that hurts but it gave a
good flavor
that's so huge you just like the flavor
like even when you dunk your chip and
salsa you don't get any
of the mass on it you just get the
watery
you just get a light coating of salsa
you're [ __ ] exposing me right now
that's like that's so you it's yeah i
know it is so mean like i don't scoop up
the nasty soggy vegetables
people who do that are disgusting i just
dip my chip in the liquid
make it a little moist you should get
restaurant style salsa i accidentally
bought it a few weeks ago and it's
exactly your type of salsa it's just the
liquid liquid it's just the liquid
interesting it's interesting it's not
good for me but it'll be good for you
like if
i was in the dating scene which i'm
obviously not and i never really was but
if i wasn't like i invited a guy over
and i made chips and salsa
and i saw him scoop up like huge amounts
of like soggy ass vegetables
i would literally tell him to get out of
my house there's no way that your own
husband doesn't do that
oh he does but see that's what marriage
is is accepting someone for their flaws
when you're dating someone like you're
looking for red flags everywhere
yeah and so that would be a deal breaker
for you yeah i guess ben like hid
that tendency of his until it was too
late but also in his defense like when
we first started dating i was being like
a liar
you know and i was like oh i love salad
you know like i was pretending like i
wasn't a four-year-old
um so i had to pretend to not be grossed
out by his
salsa tendencies got it i just i do eat
things weird
like that's a good call you know yeah
but that's just something cute about you
no i'm so cute it's crazy yeah you're
just like a little like a little portion
you don't need much
well because that's like my stepping
stone i used to just eat chips without
salsa because to me salsa is like
literally the epitome of all things
disgusting
like vegetables wet soggy spicy
and then i'm like there must be
something humid because people seem to
really enjoy chips and salsa
and then i was like oh let me just dip
my toe in the pond
and i never really evolved past that
yeah
and and that's okay but it works for you
and you know it's different strokes for
different folks and i would never
ever yuck your yums no i would never
yuck your yums either
except that's what you've been doing all
the time all the time whatever
um it's okay it's okay so i'm just
really feeling
okay thanks i'm really feeling like it's
it's just time okay yeah i think it's
time we talked about salsa and eggs long
enough
to hit you with the fast side stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and while that may be true i would oh do
you feel that no no no
i might have some pepto-bismol if you
have some rdh
um alleviation medication
you have some rdham yeah
i think i'm okay but i'll let you know
i'm feeling like you know you get that's
that like bubbling in your stomach after
you eat some salsa
it's like it's like a feeling of like
you're feeling remiss
no it's like rdh reflux yeah because
it's like this devastation and this
heartbreak like coming back up for the
second time
um so i i don't wanna i think the only
way to really truly get rid of it is to
let everyone know that today's episode
is brought to you by our patreon channel
yes that's right patreon.com the morning
toast what is patreon you ask
it is our subscription service so if you
love this show and you can't get enough
and
when the weekends come you're lonely and
sad head over patreon.com
morning toast you can subscribe to our
premium content channel for 7.99 a month
and you can get five extra episodes
every month
and the episodes are pretty diverse
they're either vlogs we're doing a lot
more vlogs in quarantine
but there's also podcast episodes and
once you sign up you actually get access
to the full library
so we've been doing patreon for like two
years so once you pay now you can
literally get access to over 200
episodes both podcasts and vlogs
tons of great vlogs tons of hilarious
podcasts we have sisters guests
it's really the morning toast but like
we're digging a little deeper on there
because you know we're behind a paywall
we feel more secure we're opening up
more family stuff so again that's
patreon.com
the morning toast for 7.99 and that's
7.99
also gets you access to our facebook
group which is only for patreon members
it's called the toast after dark and
it's pretty much the greatest subgroup
um well actually subgroup group um
on the planet so i would really
recommend becoming a patreon member and
people
the reviews are in and people are loving
it they're sickening and our next
patreon that we're going to try to film
this weekend is a great idea suggested
by someone that i'm so excited also like
nervous and i don't know how we're gonna
pull it off
but it's gonna be good it it excites me
excitement does excite me so it's
therefore exciting much like
our first story of the day i'm just
gonna get straight from the horse's
mouth on instagram
this is gonna be fabulous fabulous
fabulous taylor swift i don't know if
you've heard of her she's like a small
little artist
she's i think she's like kind of teeters
between country and pop um
but she's she's really on their eyes yes
she's on her eyes and she's dropping an
album tonight at midnight
it is her eighth studio album and it is
called fork folklore it's hard to
pronounce
called forklore for
folklore it's the l is like it's a light
out it's not like fock
but it's [ __ ] it's folklore
it's folk lore um obviously this harks
back to the clue that she dropped a few
weeks ago
oh my god yes oh my god okay
i totally forgot that we when we were
doing our zoom episodes i wanted to put
it out there that there was like a
folklore was that the word we defined so
she just gave like a tumblr account this
clue which is the definition
textbook definition of the word folklore
little did we know folklore was the
album
right but those tumblr things always end
up being true
yeah but we could never even have
dreamed it was a whole ass
album no because this is such an unlike
her thing to do because she is
easter egg bunny rabbit everything like
massive treasure
and swifty code for her to just like
write something seven palm trees
five holes in the fence like for her to
just like write something and then
put it up is like such a foreign concept
to swift he's like this feels like a
prank
no this feels like a gift no it is the
most
generous i can't i'm so humbled by this
announcement
and it's really proving that taylor
swift is just like a woman of the people
and she knows that like people are just
bored and struggling and like
all all we needed was this right so
here's here's the caption most of the
things i had planned this summer didn't
end up happening
but there is something i hadn't planned
on that did happen
this does sound like the beginning of a
pregnancy announcement
oh i guess but the photo is super moody
and
far away she said and that thing is my
eighth studio album
folklore surprise tonight at midnight
i'll be releasing my entire brand new
album of songs i've poured all of my
whims dreams fears and amusings into
i wrote and recorded this music in
isolation but got to collaborate with
some musical heroes of mine
aaron destner who has co-written or
produced 11 of the 16 songs
bonnie there who co-wrote and was kind
enough to sing on one with me
throwback thursday to boney bear william
bowery who co-wrote two with me and jack
antonoff who is basically musical family
at this point
engineered by laura sisk and john lowe
mixed by serbian guineana
and john lowe the album photos were shot
by the amazing beth garabrant before
this year i probably would have
over thought when to release this music
at the perfect time
but the times we're living and keep
reminding me that nothing is guaranteed
my gut is telling me that if you make
something you love
you should just put it out into the
world that's the side of uncertainty i
can get on board with
love you guys so much i love that last
bit by the way i love that message it's
so true like that really is what
quarantine has taught all of us it's
like nothing is guaranteed
you can plan all you want but you know
god is up there laughing in your face
i'm just thrilled like there are so many
elements of this that excite me to the
nth degree the first is obviously like a
whole new album like i feel like i just
got done really like laying down with
lover and now it's just a part of my
repertoire
and usually i have to wait like a whole
other year um from that point to a new
album
so obviously just the sheer fact that
it's coming and we don't have to wait
like
two months or even a week like it's
literally here tonight the second part
that's so exciting is that this is a
dual announcement because there's also
a music video coming out for the song
cardigan yes and
she also posted that the song will have
six the album will have 16 songs on a
standard edition but there'll be a
deluxe edition with a bonus track
but there are eight deluxe cd editions
in eight deluxe vinyl editions that are
available for one week and they're all
different from one another so there's
just like so much fanfare to be had
can you read me some of the can you read
me the tracklist yes
the one cardigan the last great american
dynasty
that like can we just talk about that
like that reminds me of miss miss
americana and the heartbreak prince i
love
she loves like a rhode island um ethel
kennedy american history moment and we
respect that
exile featuring bonnie bear my tears
ricochet
mirrorball 7 august this is me trying
illicit affairs invisible string
mad woman epiphany betty
peace hoax and then the bonus track is
the lakes
i'm gonna say that betty sounds like it
might be one of my favorite songs
something about the name something about
this whole vibe and you know she goes
hard on aesthetic when she's releasing
an album and so this is really a
departure
from the pliny vibes of lover and now
it's a little moodier
well so we have to dive in you know
taylor swift is multi-genre
she is country she is pop and this is
giving me
not a country vibe it's more in that
direction but it's not country even
though you hear folklore you think it's
like folk music with a banjo
i don't think that's what it's going to
be this is giving me like more emo
alternative like bony bear this i think
i would mix
say it's a mix of casey musgraves and
billy eilish
yes oh what a fabulous that's the mood
i'm projecting the math equation
predicting will be this album but i mean
that sounds fabulous i think whatever it
is it will be fabulous but she does go
ham on a theme a theme even reputation
so she this is all black and white it's
very you know
it's kind of reminding me and i think
this is what folklore is and she says
it's her dreams her whims her
musings i feel like these are all going
to be like diary entries yeah
of every feeling she's ever felt just
really getting in her feelings i mean if
that's the case like
ugh and i feel like these songs were
made for the quarenstein's playlist you
know that's the mood
a hundred percent i don't think she
would be releasing like a pop edm album
right now
no because it wouldn't make any sense
there's nowhere to listen to it but
she knows that people are home people
are like sitting on their porches if
they have them so jealous
and they're looking for like a nice slow
emo
song to get into you know what song i
think it's going to be most similar to
from her catalog that we already know
tell the archer
oh okay you know yeah like just that is
like very much a casey musk great spot
like heart strings tugged that might be
one of my favorite songs of hers
i'm almost just like not ready do you
know what i mean like i
literally no i know you have to get
ready you have to spend your day today
clearing your mind so that you have the
space to let this in
i feel like i just truly processed
everything that is her most recent album
lover and i finally like put together my
official ranking which took me a really
long time
and i don't know i just there's
something sad about like not that it's
going anywhere but you're departing
from like a certain era and moving into
another one which is so exciting but
i really loved the lover era i feel like
it was one of her
like her best in the sense that like she
was so happy with herself and like the
place in her life
and like the the pliny and the colorful
and the sparkly like that was great
and i'm sad to be moving on from that
but i'm embracing this
new era with just open arms i think this
is so fabulous i cannot think taylor
swift enough
for being the most generous person like
this is exactly what we needed this is
so fabulous your fans are just so
grateful for you every single day and i
just love you and thank you
yeah this is really really exciting
hopefully tomorrow we will have you know
some of our initial thoughts
but we will definitely need the entire
weekend to ruminate with this
so come monday will be the official it
wouldn't be appropriate honestly for me
to say anything about the album tomorrow
because it just wouldn't be
um it wouldn't be fair i
i hear that but i do think sometimes it
is interesting to just
share your first impression of something
and then how it
changes of all time totally i will want
to hear your first impression just as a
taylor swift stand what you think this
means for the swifties yeah et cetera
and then we'll get into it on monday i
already bought the merch it's like the
sickening cardigan
oh really um yeah and it's like knit and
chunky and has like patches it's
actually really cute i love a cardigan
i've just been ordering so many
cardigans i don't know what i'm gonna
wear them with but
i love them i know um i'm assuming it's
the cardigan referenced in the song
cardigan yeah i don't know i'm not
entirely sure though
i i really can relate to a cardigan
moment
yeah um that's very much my vibe it's a
thrill
you guys should just get through
swifties we don't have many days like
this like some artists like love to
surprise their fans like we don't get
this like we get everything meticulously
planned which we love
but just enjoy it and take it in
yeah it's gonna be a good day take it in
it's it's so exciting
okay next story some more exciting happy
news demi lovato and her boyfriend
max eric are engaged quote i knew i
loved you the moment i met you i think
it's
max ehrlich there's no l what
yeah i know i was ready to say erlich
and then i i thought it was ehrlich like
that's like such a jewish last night i i
was ready to say erlich
and then there's no l in the title in
the copy oh sorry okay magazine article
yeah you just assume it's zero like but
i think it's eric
um he popped the question on wednesday
less than four months after people
reveal that they were dating
uh max asked demi to marry him in malibu
california with a
stunning sickening gigantic diamond ring
gigantic by celebrity jeweler peter
marco
fabulous i mean this has been a very
under wraps relationship i honestly
forgot that they were dating
and if it weren't for like the fact that
he was playing piano on instagram live
once and she came in and gave him a kiss
because she didn't know he was on
instagram live
i don't think anyone would have even
known that they're dating but part of me
makes it think like
this could be it the one for her because
those private relationships are always
healthier
and always more legit than the ones you
know ben affleck and anna darmus like
literally flashing themselves in front
of the paparazzi every 10 minutes
yes but you know the more that time goes
on just i'm i'm waiting for an
engagement announcement from those two
oh i heard that they broke up like
inside sources like i don't stand or
shut my ship
i don't stand or ship like whatsoever i
made no investment in their relationship
oh i
very much did but we love a happy demi
lovato i don't think it gets any happier
than this these pictures are beautiful
she looks so happy they look like such a
happy couple
i'd love to get some happy demi news we
love a sickening
sickening engagement ring we do and we
also love you know
any sort of emotion from our favorite
artists that might compel them to write
a fabulous album
yes that is true i mean wait did you
watch the demi lovato youtube
documentary i can't remember it was
really really interesting and her love
life has had so many different
phases and she's obviously i think
someone who like likes to be in a
relationship and like
likes to feel loved and i feel like i
don't know part of me thinks that like
this might be
it yeah i mean he's so cute
he's so cute i love when you know the
biggest stars in the world data normie
yeah me too it's the best and i think it
bodes well
for the future and i would just like a
wellness for uh check on mike johnson
because this truly could have been him
this could have been him she was
obviously ready like in a place in her
life right
place where she's ready to settle down
and
he just blew it by asking to kiss her on
the first date yeah
is that what he did he did something
weird i don't know
i remember there was like some tea in
the group
that someone like was sitting next to
them on their date and like
just the conversation i can't i can't
mike johnson is so funny like every time
i think of him i think of like
him trying to ask kiki palmer out on a
date on her tv show
um which by the way got cancelled
strahan kiki and sarah which is so
strange i thought it was such a good
choice i thought it was such a good show
too
i thought it was such a great idea and
that it and it really had a future
yeah and like all those people kind of
moved on from big projects to do that
like
michael strahan was obviously good
morning america right yeah but it was a
part of gma it was an hour of gma so i'm
sure he'll just be back to a different
hour
yeah no i know but then also sarah
haynes used to be on the view kiki
palmer like gave up acting for a while
to do this every day and you would think
that they would give it more than one
season
yeah you know yeah or maybe like maybe a
lot of people
were projecting i think i maybe
mentioned this that kiki palmer's next
move could be filling in for
um the real because there's a spot open
and i think that
i still actually have high hopes that it
could be rachel lindsay because
um someone dm me on instagram she
actually is moving to la so like makes
you think makes you think
but kiki palmer would be a fabulous
selection as well
i completely agree i look forward to
seeing who that choice is me too and i
wonder where we're gonna find out
that'll be some big hosting news and we
love some hosting news
huge hosting news okay next story so
exciting one direction will be launching
an immersive website as their 10th
anniversary treat
i don't know if i would say exciting as
a as a one deer from day one
a one day or no i was a day one one deer
that's good
um i expected more than a website sorry
it's no reunion but 10 years after
forming the band is getting back
together virtually that is oh i wonder
if they would have had a different plan
if we weren't in a pandemic maybe the
currently defunct boy
band super group is preparing a new 1d
anniversary website full of immersive
offerings interactive playlists
and activations across digital platforms
according to a press release
the site set to launch on thursday that
is today will be formatted as a timeline
of the group's history from their first
audition to the beginning of their
hiatus what is that like four years
is this a joke you know it's i mean it's
a little bit i think maybe it's five or
six
history yeah it's so what you and me
got a whole
[Music]
but it's not great and it's not really
what i was expecting
i mean would it be so hard for them to
put together one song via zoom like
a new song like why would that be so bad
they're not getting back together
they're just releasing a song
or like a stripped down version of one
of their other i don't know i just feel
like yeah there was a website really
what is this 1999
no this is just not not for me but um
i hope that there are some people out
there who will get joy and pleasure from
this today and have a great day and then
go into midnight and have a great day
tomorrow and a great weekend and
you know it's hard the good parts have a
good day it's so as a one direction fan
it is so hard to have a good day
and you know at least they have so so
many albums and i actually listen to
them all the time because their music
really was sensational and i think for
sensational when they were doing it they
thought they were doing like corny
boyband like [ __ ]
bubblegum music but it really was
exceptional exceptional yeah that i'm
always looking for good albums to do
peloton scenic rides to and i think i
need to add some 1d to my repertoire i
don't even know what the best album is
maybe it's four
so mature so mature and it's misleading
because you think that it's the one
without zayn where there are four
members but it's actually just i think
their fourth album
yeah um and speaking of zane i'll be
interested to see if he posts
anything on social media i saw some of
the boys posted like pictures
and i did see zayn included it wasn't
exclusively like the four of them
which is nice because he really was a
part of the band even though he
did you know his best to take it down um
i'm
very curious if he'll be posting
anything from bucks county
yeah it'll be interesting if he doesn't
that would be lame that would be lame
like recognize where you came from honor
your past
yeah even though like i really loved one
direction
just as much if not more without zayn
because you could tell you could feel
the toxicity he brought especially
towards the end of his time there
yeah and it's like i don't want this is
how i feel about like life in general i
don't want people around who don't want
to be
here if you don't want to be here you do
not have to be here 100
if you don't want to be a part of my
favorite band i don't need you in the
band you know the band is still my
favorite with or without you
right i agree but this actually reminds
me i'm going to spend some time today
today listening to one direction you
know will you be on the website no
with their interactive timeline i don't
think it's an immersive digital
experience
and i don't think i'm going to immerse
myself in their social activations
either
you're not going to immerse yourself i
don't think so but i actually went to a
one direction concert
when they were um touring in america at
metlife and
it was literally one of the most
incredible concerts of my life me and
ben went
and five seconds of summer opened for
them and me and ben didn't really know
who they were except they sing sing that
song
i wish i would wake up with amnesia and
it was like kind of big in the states
and like a couple people knew it yeah no
i'm such like a
british one direction or the states um
and so like some people
knew it and i like connie knew it and
i'm like damn and that's where the one
direction concert was amazing but mostly
because it introduced me to five seconds
of summer who i still stand to this day
um and that concert was like one of the
highlights of my life like i was being
so annoying to ben like ben actually
likes one direction but like i was taken
to another level like
i made him get us like literally the
best seats we listened in the car ride
home
i mean the car there like every single
album it took us forever to get there
there was so much traffic ben was
literally the only man there it was just
fabulous
fabulous sounds like a fabulous evening
it really was like
that makes me miss concert so much like
that was like one of the best i've had
some of the best nights of my life
actually
at metlife stadium i have felt pure
elation
pure joy what is your most memorable
concert in the last
few years five years maybe rascal flatts
with dan and shea opening at home dell
pnc bank arts center which is my
favorite venue and i by the way i don't
like metlife
oh i mean getting there is torture but
sometimes the only
place you can see your favorite artist
taylor swift is that
i saw ed sheeran there i saw one
direction there i have to say that
probably the most formative concert
of my um recent life
was in 1989. oh that was a great one and
we had amazing seats and it was
just an explosion of color and joy
and sparkles and it remains my favorite
concert and my favorite taylor swift
album
yeah it's a great album i've been doing
uh rides to her
albums and it's making me realize you
know that's making me
realize things it's been a year of
realizing stuff for sure
kylie was on to something when she said
that yeah and that 1989
is is it's like it feels overrated
because it got so much play but it's
it's rated it's what it is it's not
overrated no it feels overrated because
of songs
like blank space which literally became
space is sickening
you know and it's sickening but it's so
it's not even scratching the surface on
the genius that is 1989
clean like there's just so many
wonderland
there are so many brilliant brilliant
unbelievably
sickening stunning and smart songs
beautiful
stunning and smart and i just love that
ear in general i feel like
it makes me sad though to think like
taylor doesn't look back on that era
positively
because it was the one right before you
know the whole snake drama
and she got so much [ __ ] back then for
her girl gang when she was like just
trying to like be popular and
i think she probably has a lot of
regrets about that um which makes me
really sad
oh i'm sorry wildest dreams like
whatever album wildest dreams is on has
to be the best taylor swift album
[Music]
and you know taylor has um like dvds for
all the concerts
except for red because red was filmed by
terry richardson remember him yeah and
he as
like as they were editing it turned out
he had multiple
counts of um sexual assault to come out
again sam and taylor did not want to be
a part of that and didn't want him to
like profit off of her music so she
never released it
which i never got to go to the red
concert and i don't even know what it
looked like or like what it was about
it's like such a mystery to me
and i found like um someone had like
professionally filmed it and sold it on
amazon
and i literally got it and i plugged it
into my dvd player and it was
legitimately from someone's iphone in
like the bottom of the pit and like i
could not see anything
i did watch the whole thing did you get
a vibe for what this i got nothing it
was so blurry like i literally got
nothing and i'm like i can't believe
amazon has
the nerve to sell this product on their
website it was
literally like homemade damn well
you tried i tried so hard okay ready for
our next story another girl we
love um who's doing well cameron diaz
says her daughter radix is quote the
best thing that ever happened to her
and her husband benji madden i love her
so much so much and she is a loving
motherhood i'm so happy for her the
actress opens up about life as a parent
during wednesday's broadcast of the
tonight show starring jimmy fallon
saying in an exclusive sneak peek of the
episode provided to people
that six-month-old daughter radix is the
best thing that ever happened to her and
her husband
quote it's been heaven jimmy she cusses
to host
love her to host jimmy fallon explaining
that her daughter is growing so fast
that she now understands why friends who
have kids previously told her to cherish
this time yeah
quote literally every single day there's
just leaps and bounds and she's not the
same baby that she was yesterday oh my
god that's how i feel about snake
mckayla yeah me too
where was yesterday yesterday is
literally gone and today is a new day
and tomorrow will be a new day
no that she's completely a different
baby she's obviously talking about
michaela like she's obviously met
mckayla because every time olivia sends
a picture of michaela i'm like who is
that child
she's so different every time i see her
she's so different so worldly so mature
she's just it's like the song growing
we do it every day we're growing in the
evening
and even when we play i mean i
i have a lot of resentment for like the
current state of the world because i
can't see michaela every single day
and i feel like i'm just missing out on
like such an important time in her life
but we are going away together um
later well not today like later next
month and
i just i cannot wait to wake up with her
every day do you know what i mean
yeah i do know what you mean and like
i'm just going to become her mother i
think
yeah no if that's okay we'll be like in
full anti-mode
yeah and i want to be helpful activated
i want to be
anti-mode activated activated
i'm so excited like and i just love her
and i feel cameron diaz on this you know
yeah i feel it hard i feel it so hard
and i love cameron diaz
i love her she's a hollywood treasure
treasure
every movie that she's in good or bad
you know on the film side
is fabulous made fabulous by her
presence agreed
and it took me a long time to realize
that and i and i rue the years that i
spent not appreciating the talent that
she is and i rue the years that i spent
just associating her as like a katherine
heigl
kate hudson jennifer aniston she is so
much more than that like
she is a goddess and i think the other
woman obviously had a lot to do with
that
but then i think that maybe we didn't
realize at the time how formative she
was in our childhood experience with her
participation in the shrek franchise
yes as fiona yes so i don't know i just
think it's worth mentioning every now
and then that cameron diaz is
not made for this earth i agree i agree
well i'm glad she's having joy fits in
final story a little news in the
streaming wars
hbo max reached 4.1 million subscribers
one month after their launch
that sounds pretty solid very solid hbo
max attracted 4.1 million overall
subscribers after its first month 18t
ceo john
stanky said on thursday lotting his team
for a flawless launch
despite the novel coronavirus pandemic
wait a t
ceo yeah watch hbo max i guess they own
hbo uh the figure includes more than one
million wholesale
customers from att packages that include
hbo max they have a
collab that's a little bit of cheating
i'm sure they you know it's a little
cheating i'm sure there's ownership
crossover so they gave it like free for
a month to like a million
yes 18 t customers and then three
million customers were normal retail
subscribers
well you know the streaming wars let's
get an update because we've been talking
about the streaming wars for a while and
since then
disney plus has come out hbo max has
come out quibby has come out anything
else
peacock peacock yes oh i forgot about
that
so where do you stand i am a peacock
peacock subscriber i'm a subscriber to
disney plus
i was momentarily a quibby subscriber
but i didn't end up using it
and then i was never an hbo max
subscriber because i wanted to be and
then i just forgot
yeah so for me it's like whatever
someone sets up for me
mostly my husband or olivia set up our
disney plus right like i have disney
plus therefore i use disney plus
i think if someone could come over and
set up hbo max and
peacock for me i would be watching them
every day peacock is so worth your time
you literally just put in your email
first of all it's totally free did you
know that oh yeah because they have ads
one commercial per episode fabulous
fabulous as long as i don't have to like
like get a login and try and remember my
password
they have bethany ever after on there
and i watched it
and they have well they have literally
like rachel zoe project they have so
many iconic bravo moments it is such a
fabulous platform
i'm so impressed by the whole thing
because i'm like who needs peacock
actually i do okay that might be and
free is free
free is free yeah no as long as i don't
have to like remember a password i'm
down so
i will definitely do that this weekend
it was so easy
yeah okay cool um so yeah i think of
over
like all the things that launched
recently i think the most successful was
disney plus i heard the figures were
like crazy
that's great um and i haven't heard yet
about peacock because it's so new but
hbmx is considered a
success i don't think quibby was
considered a success um
so good luck hbo max it is a little
steep price-wise it's like fourteen
dollars
oh but you get friends but i bought
friends for sixty dollars
um on itunes and i own that forever and
a couple months of four months of hbo
max is the same price as friends but i
am going to want to watch the gary
gianetti uh
cartoon yes happy birthday prince george
oh and i'm definitely going to want to
watch selena gomez's chef
cooking show like i don't know how i can
live without content that was made for
you
no that was truly made for me like i
love to see celebrities you know
diving into a hobby that i've never
heard that they like to do you know
yeah no that's exactly what we're
looking for yeah from our celebrity
content
um so jackie did not get a chance to
watch real housewives of beverly hills
so we'll do a full recap tomorrow
i just want to say the episode was
unbelievable okay brandi glanville
actually gets choked up like and like
there's obviously this like set up scene
where brandy is brought in to like
deliver some news yeah the one
in kyle's house like they're just
sitting around yeah no it's like kim
comes off to drop off dresses and kim's
like i have to go
brandi's in the car we're going to
dinner for her birthday and kyle's like
brandi's in the car bring her in like
it's so fake but they had to orchestrate
it in some sort of way and i wasn't mad
but like
when brandy is just like sitting in the
car not supposed to be on tv she's miked
up because you can hear her being like
oh like you know yeah um it's just so
funny how that crazy
bomb is literally delivered in front of
teddy mellencamp who is just
ill-equipped to handle that kind of
information because brandy was like we
hooked up
and teddy's like like made out like no
teddy actually no um and then this weird
thing happens where after that
conversation like the last two minutes
zoom to 24 hours ahead like literally
you see them quickly get on a plane like
it's all
in hyperlapse and they're in then
they're literally in a car
going from the airport in rome to their
hotel talking about
what brandy told them to the other women
got it so brandy told them the day
before this big trip where all the women
are going to be there so it's like
and denise i'm assuming is going denise
and garcelle are on a flight later so
when the ladies are already in rome
going to the hotel davis and garcia are
just getting to lax and all the ladies
now
they just started to tell these sabrina
because they they split up in the cars
got it like literally was the first
chance they got to tell her i feel like
maybe they would have
warned the women on the plane when they
weren't um
being filmed filmed just like to be like
hey i'm about to tell you something
crazy like it's
it is a shocking piece of news i feel
like maybe they gave lisaren a heads up
um she is an actress and by the way they
all have acted so it's like it's hard to
know
because kyle was actually being a really
good actress when brandy like came into
her room like it was so dumb
um but it was a really really good
episode and also something really
interesting that happened i don't want
to spoil too much but you got the tail
end of kyle's party first of all brandi
gets absolutely shit-faced she cannot
stand up
literally her legs don't work and you
see her literally fall 400 times i've
actually never seen a person so drunk
and then you find out later
why she got so drunk and she was like
just really anxious to be around bran um
denise and aaron but one of the
interesting parts
of the episode was hearing brandy talk
to adrien malouf because you know last
we left them adrian malouf
was furious at brandy for saying on tv
that she had a surrogate they even
blurred it
it was never actually said on tv because
adrian was suing the network like it was
so much drama
then we found out later that it was
brandy in fact saying surrogate
but she literally while she's so drunk
she's pouring drinks for everyone and
her and adrian are being pleasant with
each other
and in her confessional she's like
honestly i did this horrible thing to
adrian and she's still
after the show always been nice to me
when i see her out like and she
obviously felt so bad about it she got
like so choked up and she's like i never
said i'm sorry
and i really am sorry and then she like
blamed it on lisa vanderpump
manipulating her because she was like
you know it wasn't my idea and adrienne
actually was like yes i do know that
but brandi still said it and it was
obviously something very personal that
adrian
only told brandy because they used to be
such close friends and it was a really
sweet tender moment
okay um and just like an interesting
flashback i totally forgot that like
they had beef
yeah okay that's so exciting i can't
wait to watch was new york's on tonight
tonight
okay so we'll recap it all in total
tomorrow but the
um i'm like why can't i remember his
name brian who writes three caps
brian moylan recap is sensational okay
sensational
sweet wow exciting that is all we have
for you guys and if there's nothing else
i would like to thank you guys for
watching the morning toast millennium
warning show
where we post youtube videos monday
through friday and we're also available
as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio
iheartradio cashbox
our video podcasts are now available on
spotify so if you love listening to
podcasts on spotify you can now watch us
and if you like watching us you can also
watch us on spotify on on your mobile
device which is very exciting
and that's it thank you guys so much
we'll see you tomorrow morning we will
see you
[Music]
goodbye
you